finance madame Sylvie vermeiller vous
avez la parole ma chère collègue
[Applaudissements]
monsieur les affaires sociales madame
monsieur lui rapporteur chers collègues
la commission des finances a souhaité se
saisir pour ravi sur l'ensemble du
plfssr au regard de ses effets certain
sur les finances publiques
notre système des retraites repose sur
le principe de répartition selon lequel
les cotisations des actifs financent les
pensions des retraités soit
345,1 milliard en 2021 dans le scénario
retenu par le gouvernement et jugé
optimiste par la commission des finances
avec une croissance de 1% et un taux de
chômage à quatre et demi pour cent le
déficit du système atteindrait 13,5
milliards d'euros fin 2030 et 150
milliards en cumulent pour les dix
années à venir la stabilisation relative
des dépenses ne compensera pas la baisse
des ressources qui provient de la
réduction du nombre de cotisants de la
diminution de l'emploi public donc des
cotisations et de la réduction des
transferts en provenance des branches
familles et chômage en dépense le
Conseil d'orientation des retraites
souligne que les effets de la hausse du
nombre de pensionnés qui seront 3
millions en 2027 contre 19 aujourd'hui
seront partiellement atténués par la
stabilisation voir la baisse du niveau
des retraites rapportées au PIB
les dépenses progresseront néanmoins de
1,8% par an en volume sur le quinquennat
progression incompatible avec l'objectif
du gouvernement de réduction du déficit
public à l'horizon 2027 la réforme est
centrée sur une majoration de l'âge
d'ouverture des droits de 62 à 64 ans et
l'accélération de la durée de cotisation
portée à 43 annuités des 2027 le
gouvernement y carte l'hypothèse d'une
hausse de cotisation qui réduirait le
pouvoir d'achat de 442 euros annuels par
cotisant en 2030 ou la diminution des
pensions qui seraient de 719 euros
annuels par retraité en 2030 pour
compenser le déficit
la progression de l'emploi des seniors
constitue un enjeu majeur puisque bien
qu'en est hausse depuis 2003 celui-ci
reste inférieur à la moyenne européenne
de
59,6%. une attention sur mesure devra
être portée au 55 64 ans car la réforme
de 2010 avait induit une progression du
chômage pour ces classes d'âge
le montant des réserves placé par les
régimes de retraite atteignaient fin
180,4 milliards d'euros dont 86,5
milliards d'euros à l'agir Carco qui va
pouvoir réfléchir à l'utilisation de ces
excédents confortés par la réforme la
perspective de recettes supplémentaire
pour le système des retraites mais
également pour les autres branches de la
sécurité sociale et le budget de l'État
doit nous inciter à réviser le devenir
du Fonds de réserve des retraites
admirablement géré depuis 2001
afin de nous prémunir d'autres aléas
démographiques n'est-il pas
indispensable de fléchir des recettes
supplémentaires liées à la réforme vers
ce fond qui sécuriserait notre système
par répartition le projet de loi
initiale propose plusieurs mesures
d'accompagnement estimées à 5,9
milliards d'euros en 2030 année prévu
pour l'équilibre du système mais ce
retour à l'équilibre est fragilisé par
les amendements du Gouvernement déposés
en première lecture à l'Assemblée
nationale estimée à 800 millions à
l'horizon 2030
vigilance sur ce point la réforme
prévoit également qu'à compter du 1er
septembre 2023 les régimes des retraites
des industries électriques et gazières
de la RATP de la Banque de France
d'éclairs et employés de notaire et des
élus du Conseil économique social et
environnemental n'aphilie plus de
nouveaux cotisants ces régimes sont
actuellement équilibrés soit au moyen
d'une taxe spéciale soit au moyen d'une
subvention d'équilibre versée par l'État
soit structurellement déficitaire le
montant des cotisations ne couvrant pas
celui des pensions
la fermeture de ces régimes entraînera
mécaniquement une attrition du nombre de
cotisants pour les caisses concernées je
m'étonne que les conséquences
financières ne soient pas d'ores et déjà
prévues notamment le reversement par la
CNAV et l'agirco des cotisants des
cotisations des nouveaux affiliés à
l'instar de ce qui fonctionne pour la
SNCF le relèvement de l'âge d'ouverture
des droits de 2 ans concernent également
tous les agents de la fonction publique
il ne devrait avoir que peu d'effets car
l'âge de départ est déjà de 63 ans et 8
mois pour laisser dentaires et 60 ans
pour les actifs le solde technique du
compte d'affectation spéciale pension
pourrait être de 0,7 milliards d'euros
en 2027 puis 1,1 milliard d'euros en
2030 de nouveau je préconise une
immobilisation de ces excédents au sein
du Fonds de réserve des retraites afin
de garantir l'avenir des retraites
publics au-delà de ces remarques la
commission des finances du Sénat estime
que ce projet de loi va dans le sens
d'un rééquilibrage du système des
retraites et que cet objectif doit être
soutenu je vous remercie merci madame le
rapporteur
[Applaudissements]
nous allons maintenant passer à la
discussion de la motion